[Music]
in our house we call it d-day
it was the day everything changed and
you know i've made uh i've gone public a
lot about
my pornography addiction
and then there's a lot of people who who
say you could never really be addicted
to pornography or whatever and it's
always been said that but
all i knew is i couldn't stop that's all
i knew
for me it was a numbing device
it was something that i went to when i
was sad when i was happy
and i always went back to it and it left
me unfulfilled and i had to get
to get more
just to get a feeling of fulfillment but
then i would be left empty again so
it was a cycle i couldn't stop
but it was also a secret that i held
from my family my wife and
the whole thing and
my wife finally confronted me on it
and let me tell you what was what was so
wild
and and really really strange
is that i was the question i was asking
was
why doesn't she believe me
but the question i should have been
asking was why did i lie
you know i mean like think about that
there's two same it's all in the context
is the same
and i'm sitting here lying and wondering
why she won't believe me
that's all out focused it was all her it
was the responsibility it was on her
in order to
make me right like you should believe me
because i'm telling you this but i was
lying
i was lying i don't i don't enjoy this
no i got no problem i don't do any of
this and then
and why doesn't she believe me
but once it
switched into why am i lying
all of a sudden it went inward
all of a sudden i had to ask myself
the questions i had been avoiding
for years and years and years
and it was like hey man you have an
issue
why aren't you doing something about it
and
and like i said and i would pull out
that card of excuses and
this and i would say well you know i'm a
man and you know man we need to we i
have a high sex drive and this kind of
stuff and i'll pull out that card and
then my wife declined it
that credit card was done it was expired
and she was out
and you know what tim
what's so crazy is that i was like fine
buy
leave
you know i'm terry crews i can get any
woman i want in fact
i will and you know what this is a
normal thing in hollywood
divorce is is pretty normal and it's not
a big deal in fact my career won't
suffer
and
nobody cares if i lose my family
hollywood certainly doesn't
and it's you and then i listen to myself
talking like that
and i went who were you
like i didn't like that guy
and i started to have internal
conversations
with myself and i was like man
this is not
who
you say you are
and i realized i was two different
people
and
when you have a double life when you
and when i say a double life what i mean
is
i was more concerned with the image
i was more concerned with the image of
terry crews
rather than who terry crews really was
and i and it was two different people
and
once i started to
try to put them together
my world crumbled everything that i knew
everything that i i was around
everything that
i thought i stood for
i thought i was like yeah you know women
are equal and the whole thing but
nothing in my behavior
would
would do that or even said that
and in fact i thought i was more
valuable than all the women in my life
simply because i was a man
simply because of the culture i was in i
grew up in black culture and hip-hop
culture
in sports culture
and there was a lot of misogyny it was a
lot of you're the man dawg hey man you
better get your girl in line
you know that kind of these kind of
words these kind of and it wasn't looked
at it was looked at as like yo man you
know you control your wife
or your girl you actually owned her i
remember
in the nfl going to the strip club and
we'd be
in the club and with all the guys and
the whole thing and the girls be up
there on stage and
one of them would come down and actually
want to talk to the players and i would
look at
her like okay you know she start talking
you know i gotta get i gotta do this for
my kids and then and you're like stop
stop stop stop stop
you're like you're ruining
the experience
because you're becoming a human being
right before my eyes
i like you to be a picture i want you to
be a doll a
a mannequin
i mean
tim
once you start i mean once you open that
can of worms
it's literally like a domino effect like
everything
started to fall on itself
and i said i i went through a huge huge
just
and then i got to say this because
in my culture
when i grew up
you know therapy was looked at as
ridiculous and
because they
i where i grew up it was like you can't
cure crazy that was the term
it was like if you're crazy you can't
cure it
my father being an alcoholic he went to
a
psychologist one time
and uh and i remember i was probably
around 12 13 years old and i'm like wow
i think you know my dad's finally gonna
get some help and the whole thing and uh
dude it was crazy because uh like a week
later the psychologist killed himself it
was on the front page of the newspaper
my god
and i went
that don't work you know my whole
mindset was like huh
like did my father kill him like you
know did he did he say something that
made this guy jump off a bridge and he
got literally jumped off a bridge
i was like what that doesn't work
and so i had in my mind
that all this therapy stuff is mumble
jumbo you know
and so there was a there was a block
there was a resistance to that
and i i finally saw a counselor who said
you need to go
to this place and get some therapy and i
was like oh no you know
and i remember and my wife said look you
know what if you don't do this like
there's no hope of us ever coming back
together because we had split up at that
time
and so i went and i said all right i'll
give it a shot and i'm sitting there in
this room with these people and harry
may i interject for one second oh yeah
go ahead
one question so did did you guys
sort of split at that point or things on
ice because of how you handled the
situation
d-day in that conversation or was it the
subject
matter like the addiction itself and
other things
i guess i'm asking was it what you did
or was it how you
handled what you did or something else
it was what i did because what happened
was i confessed
to
a
infidelity that happened 10 years
earlier
as a result of this addiction because
you know i i i went to a massage parlor
and got a hand job and
i vowed i would never ever tell anybody
you know it was one of them things but i
was it was at the beginning of my career
i was i was in vancouver i was by myself
i thought i would never be there i
thought i'd never do something like that
but you know it was wild because i found
myself in those circumstances and i did
it but i vowed i would never tell i was
like i'm taking this secret to the grave
man this is never ever coming out but my
wife
constantly she was like no you did
something she said you're something
you're not telling me
and she knew and again like i said i was
lying
the whole time you know and
she could feel that you know i mean you
could feel when your significant other
is not telling you the truth and it was
just there was something she didn't know
and when i told her
i remember just
it came out and i remember she's going
that's it like
wow
who am i living with like she had no
idea
and that was the thing because i was i
had
put an image in front of her and what
was so crazy is that she was married to
this image it wasn't fair it wasn't fair
to her there's no honesty in a
relationship because you have to cover a
lie with another lie
and then it just keeps continuing to
grow i mean we were we were getting
farther and farther apart
is what was happening and she was she
knew it she felt it
and
that was the d-day moment and she said
i'm out
she's like that's it
you can't come home
and if you have to show me that you want
this that you want actually want to do
something and i like i said in the
beginning i was like i'm fine
and then i realized i was like you know
what because the whole thing was
it was about her
and it's little bitty questions it was
just like man
you know maybe it's me
and the real realization that hit me
that it was me
that it was
you